a modeling agency in Chicago but the
first one I went to they were like I
don't know when what's that thing on
your face you might have to have that
removed and it was you know not the
warmest kindest fuzziest introduction
but the the moral of you know the fact
that and I had wanted when I was a kid
because I don't most kids don't like
anything that sets them apart I wanted
to get my mole removed and I had asked
my mother I want to get my mole removed
and she was like okay that's fine but
you know just remember you don't know
what that scar will look like you know
what your mole looks like but really the
interesting thing is that's the thing
that made me most memorable you know
before I was Cindy Crawford people were
like who's that model with the beauty
mark and and I think that's what I love
like reminding my daughter when we have
things that we think make us different
it's that uniqueness that is you it's
oftentimes the very thing that sets you
apart from everybody else so it was
learning to embrace that which is easier
said than done